[Music]
Chucky's show with how Rudnick hey guys
did you watch that Tony Awards last
night there was a lot of music in the
Oscars show I mean who was hosting that
Seth MacFarlane or Michael Buble they
gave out a lot of trophies last night
but there was some important ones that
you didn't see and we're gonna give them
out right here on the grouchy's get it
oscars Oscar the Grouch the grouchy's
that's what we're calling this deal with
it we're starting off with a biggie the
award for best neck Barbara Walters with
her dog collar throat thing came in a
close second but the winner sandy
Bullock congratulations on your throat
abs sandy and now the Award for Best
anti-semitic moment it's a tie between
Ted's speech I was born
Theodore Shapiro and I would like to
donate money to Israel and continue to
work in Hollywood forever thank you I am
Jewish and a guest appearance by a Nazi
big old pile that and now the lucius
malfoy award goes to a four-way tie
between Claudia Miranda Paul and Jay
Addison her Hallberg and Karen Baker
Landers for good-looking long-haired
dudes here's a hotly contested award the
David Spade and Chris Farley Ord goes to
Kristen Chenoweth and Adele hey Belle
what are you wearing
lay off me I'm starving but I thought
Adele gave a beautiful tearful
acceptance speech so many people to
thank Sir Ian McKellen Harry Potter
Manchester United Dame Judi Dench Big
Ben Parliament the knights of the round
table Downton Abbey I'm gonna have
myself a cry and the Helen Keller award
for literacy goes to Renee Zellweger who
apparently can't read go ahead
[Music]
not once but twice there it is Skyfall
her lip collagen injections must have
rendered her blind wow it's the how the
audience really feels award and it goes
to William Shatner who was either
sleeping playing words with friends or
sexting with George Takei the BuzzFeed
gif of the night goes to Sandra Bullock
as of taping it's not on BuzzFeed yet
but by the time we post it I bet it will
be congratulations sandy you've won two
of these dumb things the Skyfall award
goes to Jennifer Lawrence falling what's
up Katniss you can win the Hunger Games
when you can't walk up four stairs more
like fall on your ass and I'm gonna let
you finish award goes to grant Heslov
for pushing Ben Affleck out of the way
athletes ready to talk and he shoves him
out of the way grant slow your roll
nobody's there to hear you guy from True
Lies what Affleck more Affleck and the
last appearance in America award goes to
jean-claude Val Jean Dujardin good
evening
[Music]
now it's time for the biggies of the
show first the most unnecessary award it
was a long ass show that was short on
quality and the nominees are the Chicago
Tribune the Dreamgirls tribute Michelle
Obama Dancing with the Stars and Dancing
with more stars the Bond Taj that looks
like some kind of super cut off YouTube
and the winner all of Seth MacFarlane's
jokes
I thought we cut this joke but really
want to do it and now for our final
award of this very special night the
most Awkward award the nominees are the
Avengers banter and Here Come on some
hero nominee right Shirley Bassey
feeling herself up during Goldfinger
John Travolta's pronunciation of late
mr. rob name is Oh happiness and the
winner is Ben Affleck's awkward marital
problems I want to thank you for working
on our marriage for half 10 Christmases
it's it's it's good it is work but it's
the best kind of work and there's no one
I'd rather work with hey you might be
sleeping at Damons tonight but at least
you got Oscar gold
yikes it's kind of a rough show huh how
long ago MacFarlane makes fun of it on
Family Guy
salude your dream Oscar host B tell us
in the comments section below and best
answer gets a screen junkies t-shirt
thanks for watching the grouchy's I'm
Hal Rudnick by bike
[Music]